I think government should do three
things because I would argue that we're
actually having a bit of a crisis right
now you know I just got stuck in hideous
traffic coming across London you know
London has an infrastructure problem but
the web has a much much bigger Internet
sorry has a much much bigger
infrastructure problem if you like and I
think the government should focus on
three things firstly we have got to
improve the state of our digital
infrastructure urgently you know you
don't have to be a rocket scientist to
see that South Korea knock it out the
park all the time in terms of the
economy and productivity partly because
they have that superfast infrastructure
that's one big piece of the puzzle and
somewhere that government can be more
aggressive secondly we have an absolute
crisis in gender on the internet massive
huge enormous the percentage of women in
the tech and creative industries I saw a
report just this week have gone down
there are now nearly double the
percentage of women in Parliament that
is probably marginally older than the
tech sector double it's a disaster it's
a disaster because power money product
design everything is worse and
imbalanced and asymmetrical so that's
the second thing I think they should
intervene and the third thing is enough
thank you in a broader a broader skills
crisis which I you know worked on for a
while and no we still have massive
issues codons that jobs that we need to
fill and a massive issue in broader
digital skills let alone the skills of
our establishment and parliamentarians
and they are free to me very tangible
areas that government could intervene
they don't even have to touch a big tech
company to make a big shift in those
areas
you